every two seconds someone in this  country needs blood that's according to  the red cross  so the u.s is now experiencing a severe  shortage  all across the country senator catherine  cortez masto donated blood at the  american red cross today just to  raise awareness in our community right  now there is an  urgent call for donors especially those  with type o blood  if anybody was here after october 1 2017  you saw the need not only for blood at  that time but you saw the impact that  red cross had  as part of the community coming in  supporting our community supporting the  families  the victims of survivors and we had a  blood shortage at that time  that it's no different now now you can  make an appointment to donate at red  cross website we also have a list of  upcoming blood drives for you on  8newsnow.com